Тут взагалі, на жаль, згнила зовсім. Треба все поміняти.
Цей занедбаний дитячий майданчик у санаторії на Львівщині -
тепер робоче поле для Сергія - вимушеного переселенця з Києва.
У столиці чоловік довго працював рієлтором.
Перед війною завершував власноруч споруджувати свій будинок під Києвом.
Нині будівельницький запал спрямовує на нову роботу - він уже кілька тижнів завідує господарством санаторію.
Пішли, взяли новеньке, зачистили і побудували нове. Ось така робота.
За фахом Сергій інженер-електрик, понад усе любить майструвати.
Каже: саме завдяки цьому він майже одразу після переїзду на захід України знайшов роботу.
Я дуже полюбляю робити саме руками. Лагодити, щось робити з нуля. Мені дуже цікаво, щоб був результат.
От його не було, а зараз стоїть. Для мене це внутрішнє задоволення.
Без армійського досвіду на військову службу чоловіка не беруть.
Тож поки працює в задоволення, хоча й мріє повернутися додому.
Я б вже повернувся. Але ж бачите - якщо почав, то вже треба закінчити.
Ще одному переселенцеві Дмитру повертатися немає куди.
Чоловік приїхав з Ізюма - міста, яке майже повністю знищили російські війська.
З десятої вечора приблизно починався обстріл.
Літаки, з літаків починалося, потім били "Гради", "Смерчі" і вся артилерійська техніка.
Ми не розуміли, що це, просто по звуку було чути.
А потім довелося тікати, бо не можна було це все терпіти просто. У нас діти, ми за дітей боялися.
Дмитро залишився на Львівщині разом із сином Давидом.
Дружина й двоє доньок - виїхали в Німеччину.
У тому ж санаторії чоловік тепер і живе, і працює сантехніком - так само, як і в Ізюмі.
Тішиться, що має роботу, але є "але".
Шкода, розумієте, що не у своєму місті. Так, я тут почуваюся в безпеці, але не вдома. Це відчуття не передати.
Як вигнанець якийсь, переселенець, біженець. Хоча робота чудова, керівництво чудове.
Допомагали і речами, і порадами. Якось вони… співпереживають. Я дуже їм вдячний.
І наш директор, коли в нього спитали про житло, - без питань, нехай живуть. Ці люди розуміють нас.
А що ми можемо у відповідь? Ми дякуємо і їм, і Богу, що прихистили нас.
Професії і Дмитра, і Сергія - робітничі.
Саме таких вакансій нині найбільше, кажуть в обласних центрах зайнятості на Львівщині,
Хмельниччині, Тернопільщині, Прикарпатті, Черкащині.
За даними порталу "OLX Робота", у березні цьогоріч найбільш затребуваними фахівцями на ринку стали будівельники й водії.
Українці з такими навичками потрібні нині не лише вдома.
Будівельний майданчик у Польщі. Навіть тут відчутне відлуння війни в Україні.
Як і всі українці, які вже деякий час працюють у Польщі, я замислююся над тим, аби повернутися в Україну й допомагати.
Але в мене тут дружина з дитиною. Залишати їх самих у чужій країні - неправильно.
Більшість працівників на цьому будівництві - з України. Вони всі переймаються одним питанням.
Українські будівельники дуже багато значать для польських забудовників.
Якщо ми втратимо робітників, компанії буде складно знайти нових.
Що більше чоловіків поїдуть з Польщі, то менше робочих рук у нас буде для нових проєктів.
Цей будинок майже готовий - на щастя для керівниці будівельного проєкту.
Тут усе за планом. Але колеги розповідали мені, що втратили до 40 відсотків працівників.
Проєкти, які вони мали починати нині, довелося відкласти, бо в підрядників бракує робітників.
Це нині не єдина проблема для будівельної галузі в Польщі.
Будматеріали зросли в ціні на 20-30 відсотків від початку війни.
Вартість сталі пішла вгору ще стрімкіше - вона подорожчала приблизно в півтора рази. Будувати стає все дорожче.
Проблеми у сфері логістики, які спричинила війна, так само сприяють зростанню цін.
Більше третини водіїв вантажівок у Польщі - українці.
Олександр Фаренек очолює транспортну компанію.
Він сам - українець, намагається переконати принаймні частину водіїв залишатися в ЄС.
Через війну в Україні зараз бракує українських водіїв.
Наші хлопці поїхали додому, захищати свою країну.
Навіть ті, хто досі тут, замислюються над поверненням додому.
Поки що нам вдається переконати частину з них залишитися.
Адже в деякі регіони України зараз просто неможливо дістатися через бойові дії.
Водії-українці опинилися в безвихідному становищі.
Ти розумієш, я не можу ні їсти, ні пити. Я в магазин заходжу, я розумію, що мої діти, мої рідні…
Вони голодують зараз, це сто відсотків! Мені шматок у рота не лізе, розумієш?!
І поїхати до них - я до них не доїду, я до них просто не доїду, я фізично не зможу доїхати.
Я нічого не можу зробити, це безвихідь.
Я нічого не хочу: ні грошей, нічого. Я молю Бога, щоб вони були живими й здоровими і все.
Тим часом український уряд закликає усіх, хто може - працювати, аби підтримувати економіку.
Для бізнесу запровадили податкові пільги, замість 20 відсотків ПДВ дозволили платити два відсотки від обігу.
Однак ті, хто мав свою справу в зонах бойових дій, втратили практично все. І змушені починати все спочатку.
До цього віконечка у центрі Львова з самого ранку підходять покупці - по смачні пироги, галети, каву й чай.
А ближче до обіду - вишиковується черга.
Власники вуличного кафе - Сергій з Ірпеня й Іван з Бородянки.
Сергій до війни мав власний кулінарний блог та інтернет-магазин. Іван працював баристою.
На останні заощадження ризикнули відкрити міні-заклад.
Над назвою довго не думали. "Кііт" - це назва Сергієвого блогу й ім'я його кота - містер Кіт.
Проходили повз віконечко, там було написано "оренда", зателефонували і все дуже швидко склалося.
Основна мета була щось робити, щоб не думати. Щоб постійно не жити в цьому стані.
І хотілось щось робити не тільки для себе, а для суспільства, як зараз всі роблять, всі допомагають.
Половину грошей, які вдається заробити, хлопці переказують родичам у теробороні Київщини.
Хоча спершу мріяли хоча б "відбити" оренду й комунальні.
Перші дні - спочатку 130 гривень, другий день - 148 за 12 годин…
Хоча які 12-14 годин, ми працювали з сьомої до дев'ятої.
Ми вже думали зачинятися. Але потім і пости почали про нас писати, і сила Фейсбуку, як люди кажуть.
Сергієві та Івану допомагає подруга Дарина з Ніжина.
Утрьох ледь встигають готувати їжу на день.
Пироги за домашніми рецептами Сергія печуть вночі на орендованій квартирі.
У нас була вчора черга 20 людей - ми просто не встигаємо.
Ми 12 пирогів продали за півтори години зранку і вже не було їжі.
А я рахував: щоб відбити оренду, нам треба шість пирогів у день зробити.
А в перші два дні у нас було дві людини і три людини за день, і ми вже хотіли закриватися.
А зараз мова іде про те лише, щоб встигати. Трошки поспати і знову працювати.
Сергій каже, що готовий захищати країну, якщо буде потрібно. Але поки є можливість, хоче працювати.
Кожен має робити, що може. Мені здається, більше користі ми принесемо тут, ніж в перший же день просто загинемо.
Мені здається, в цьому і різниця України від Росії - у нас не посилають гарматне м'ясо.
Наша армія чудова, і ми підтримуємо її, як можемо, ось таким от способом.
У новому для себе місті хлопці почали нову справу й нове життя.
Хоча, як і мільйони українців, про таке вони ніколи не мріяли.